since we've been talking about love
can you um last time i talked to you
about meaning of life a little bit but
here has it's a weird question to ask a
computer scientist but
has love for other human beings for
for things for the world around you
played an important role in your life
have you um
you know it's easy for a world-class
computer scientist uh
yeah you could even call yourself like a
physicist everything
to be lost in the books is the
connection to other humans
love for other humans played an
important role i love my kids
uh i love my wife i love my parents
um uh you know i
uh um i'm probably not not different
from most people and loving their family
uh and and in that being very important
uh
in my life uh now i should remind you
that you know i am a theoretical
computer scientist
if you're looking for deep insight about
the nature of love you're probably
looking in the wrong place to ask me
but uh but sure it's been important but
is it
uh is there something from a computer
science perspective to be said about
love is there uh
or is that is that even beyond into the
realm of beyond
the realm of consciousness there was
there was this great uh
cartoon i think it was one of the
classic xkcds where it's a it shows like
a heart
and it's like you know squaring the
heart taking the four-year transform of
the heart
you know integrating the heart you know
uh uh
you know each each thing and then it
says you know my normal approach is
useless here
i'm so glad i asked this question i
think there's no better way to
uh to end this all right i hope we get a
chance to talk again this has been an
amazing
cool experiment to do it outside yeah
really glad you made it out yeah well i
appreciate it a lot it's been a pleasure
and i'm glad you were able to come out
to austin
thanks
you